so let's let's do this so it's now the
third night of the reignition of
protests and it's and
it's what we got uh what is it to
washington dc
new york and philadelphia yeah east
coast wave you live there
yeah they surrounded you they attacked
you tell me what happened brother so
just like you were eating dinner tonight
you didn't know the rides were going on
same thing happened to me last night i'm
just hanging out with my family we're
having dinner
i hear a helicopter overhead hanging
really low
i go on twitter i check it out turns out
that a black lives matter protest
riot had tried to lay siege to the
fourth district police department
in washington dc and so i'm eating
dinner i'm hearing the helicopters i'm
with my kids i read twitter real quick
and i'm like oh my god they're doing it
again and this time
walking distance from my neighborhood
walking distance from my house
so i jump out i'm like guys i'm out i
got to go kids are kind of used to this
by now daddy's got to go to work
so i jump out and i run up to uh georgia
avenue where the fourth district police
department was and i get there and
there's already hundreds of riot cops
out
i go up to the police station and
they've already had bashed in numbers of
windows on the first floor and the
second floor apparently they attempted
to
sort of run in and take over the police
the police department there
and things were kind of chilling out a
little bit and i was walking around and
sort of filming and i took a couple good
pictures
and i was done filming i was just
standing there and uh these
these like four antifa kids all
in their black gear with their matching
pink
matching pink gas mask that they all
ordered off
the antifa wish list that they have on
amazon yeah they do and they they were
like a little team they come up to me
and this guy's like this is our space
you have to leave
what this is our space you have to leave
and funny enough i was actually just
getting ready to go
but then when antifa guy comes up to me
and tells me it's time to leave what am
i going to say
so all of a sudden i'm staying i'm like
no there's no way i'm going anywhere
and so they tried to push me around for
a little bit and bully me out of there
two three four five of them come up and
i'm not going anywhere and it kind of
defuses for a second and i'm just
hanging out a little bit more
and then they come up to me again and
then there's like a group of four and
then five and then six and then ten
and then there's like 20 of them and now
i'm surrounded by antifa i'm surrounded
by sort of uh black lives matter type
people
just sort of random street thugs are
there and they
they circle and they circle me and
they're screaming at me they're saying
you know
white people don't belong in this city
get out of here you're a gentrifier and
i tried to engage with them i tried to
have a conversation
like man you got the wrong guy i spent
10 years helping african-american kids
in this city turn around public charter
schools
trying to sort of explain you know i'm
like hey i'm here and they're like but
what whose side are you on
whose side are you on whose side are you
on man and in my head
i'm thinking okay gotta say nothing if i
say i'm on their side just to diffuse
it's gonna like
start to rewire my own brain this is the
reason why they do struggle sessions so
i'm like forget it
i don't say anything more and more
people come up and i'm starting to get
nervous at this point and there's
probably 20 or so people
i i walk slowly towards the police line
as they are pushing me and pushing me
and there's probably 20 or 30 people at
this point
there's individual young black men just
staring me in the eyes with these like
very angry angry just
just intense eyes are just waiting to
pounce on me by getting up in my face
that i pull out my camera i start to
record then the umbrellas come out
right so there's like umbrellas all
around me all my face you can see it on
my video if you go to uh jack murphy
live
on twitter you can see the periscope
that i did last night
and you can hear the vile things that
they're saying to me white people get
out of here you don't belong here
all kinds of nasty stuff they're
streaming at me to stop recording this
is our space get out of here get out of
here get out of here and then like
another four or five guys show up that
looked like they were ready to go okay
and that's when i started to think oh
man i'm actually i'm actually in a
little bit of trouble here
and right as the energy was peaking
right as it looked like i was probably
about ready to get like
literally jumped by 30 guys i feel uh
somebody grabbed me from behind they
grab my belt
and they just yank me back like 20 feet
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait hold
on the cops
how tall are you i'm 6'4 250. exactly
okay so they came up behind me
swat team you know assault rifle the
whole thing
sorry guys not an assault rifle it's a
rifle that looks like you're right
so they grabbed me by the belt and they
yank me through and all of a sudden boom
i'm back behind the police line i'm like
oh god i got my hands
my hands up i'm like i'm complying i'm
complying and uh they were like you had
any weapons on you no
and then they walked me back and they're
like dude we just saved you like yeah
they said that they said that they're
like yeah it was about you were about
ready to get just
jumped right then and they saved me
after i was protesting their protests
i'm like i'm not going anywhere
i'm holding my ground they kept saying
this is our city i'm like dude i have
lived here for 30 years
i live walking distance from here my
kids go to school in the city
and you're going to tell me it's not my
town and that's what this whole thing is
right it's like this is our space
this is our space it can't be in our
space they don't live there these little
antifa guys i can see their eyes and
it's so weird when everybody has masks
on
because you really can see their eyes
and you can see the intensity in their
eyes and you can see
the anger and the seething rage and the
funny thing that i noticed is that when
you refuse
to bow to their intimidation it just
makes them so mad
that's what they want what they're
looking for is they want to
they want to know that you know
they've caused you pain yep and if you
don't experience pain
or acknowledge it because it's not just
about being hurt it's about them
knowing you know they hurt you they want
they want you to be like that was
me i did that yep they wanted to bully
me out of my own town
out of my own city so what you said that
it rewires your own brain to acknowledge
that you're on there that's so
cool it's true it is true it's true it's
the whole point of the struggle sessions
is to get you to say things that you
don't believe in and then you start
believing it what is a struggle session
i've never heard oh struggle session i
believe it comes from communist china
where they went into the countryside and
around and they just gathered up
everybody who wasn't
you know with the communist effort and
they made them you know swear fealty and
like do all these things i'm not an
expert on it
but i know that the intention there is
to rewire your brain and break down your
defenses by getting you to repeat things
that hey
you know are not true and then b that
are in line with the authoritarian
totalitarian state that's trying to
control you
and when i refused to do it dude they
flipped they thought that they were
gonna
they thought they were gonna bully me
now i had run into a guy that i knew
from twitter there and he is much
smaller than me and we got separated and
he did get assaulted he got head-butted
and punched
and chased out and he ran he ran the
other way i drifted towards the police
and i kind of knew the whole time the
cops were there right so i'm surrounded
by all these people and they're
screaming at me and cussing at me and
threatening me
i'm like the police are right there if
they assault me the cops will be on this
and it'll be just fine
and they just kept pushing and pushing
and pushing but this the cops surprised
me
when they grabbed me and just yanked me
through and all of a sudden i'm on the
other side of the police line
and that's when they all thought over
there like oh he's a cop he's a cop he's
a cop like yeah
he's like dude i i mean i love my law
enforcement officers and friends and
family and all that but like i grew up
not really being a big fan of police
when when
someone who is over six feet tall and
what you said 250 yep
they automatically assume you must be a
cop no matter what right that's the
thing
so uh there's also i guess people are
saying there's audio issues i don't know
literally no idea how it just like
instantly the other day just the
audio went dropping cat and we're like i
have no idea what it is cat pulled it
out
and then i think yeah the cat like
jiggled a cord or something there was a
really there's a really funny moment
where the camera started shaking like
crazy and we were like whoa what's
happening
and she was like scratching herself and
hitting the camera oh my god anyway
the uh yeah so so there have been a
bunch of instances there was
there were viral videos of like three
guys who were wearing combat boots or
like some kind of work boots
and then they got pointed out there's
like a big protest happen in toronto and
they were like those guys are cops this
is proof
so there's tons of instances where
regular looking guys
who might wear i mean let me let me stop
a second you know in dc everybody wears
the same kind of north face stuff
yeah it's like anybody who knows dc
knows what i'm talking about
you go to these like wherever you go
everyone's wearing north face jackets
and khakis and it's like the same outfit
or the same style yeah
they'll see someone like that and think
they clearly aren't one of us
you're a cop you're a cop you don't fit
in and it's like a regular dude like
eating you know nachos at a mexican
restaurant and they start screaming
you're a cop
like you you were at a restaurant is
that what you're doing no i was at home
this is how you guys see how close it
was to me
is that i heard the copper the cop
chopped her the cop
chop capture cop chopped her can we edit
that out somehow
i love it the cop shop keep it in the
chopstick the police helicopter hovering
basically over my
my house and when i saw that there was
this happening right in my neighborhood
i just jumped up i literally left my
dinner on the table and i had to go
i gotta bring it back to the intro so
why are they out there
in washington dc in particular was
because of this one incident where
a black kid was on a moped without a
helmet
the cops saw him flipped on the lights
because it's illegal
and instead of talking to the cops he
sped off on the moped so now he's like a
fugitive running away from the cops so
the cops chased him
and as they're chasing him he gets hit
by another car whoa
the third car and he ends up dying right
when they blame the cops for that this
is like two or three nights ago yeah
they blame the cops for that
and it's a tragedy it sucks when
somebody gets killed obviously
you know but if the guy just would have
stood there he would have been fine it's
not the police fault so instead they use
this they don't it doesn't matter what
the reason is
they're always just looking for any
reason any reason to rile people up
and so when i was there i noticed it was
just sort of like regular
townsfolk let's say and then the black
lives matter banner showed up and then
the antifa crew showed up
and then you could just tell like the
the medics were there and then all of a
sudden you could tell that
they had like rallied the troops to come
all the way uptown this is not downtown
this is not
by the main protest zones not by the
white house this is not where any
really of this has been going on which
is why i was so incensed i had actually
decided to leave the street reporting up
to
fearless people like shelby talcott and
elijah dc right right squad
yeah they they do a tremendous job you
know and they're out there but
you know they have a little bit of a
different demo than i do i've got three
kids and a family and the whole thing
and it's like
i have to stop putting myself in danger
like that but this was in my
neighborhood elijah schaefer got punched
in the face oh he got bloodied up
yeah man we we had elijah on the show
what was a month ago
two weeks ago yeah a few weeks ago no
more than that more than that i was like
a month ago two at least
so he he's another one of these dudes
who goes out there and does this
reporting i i saw a video where he was
like his face was swollen and he was
bleeding and he was still reporting
yeah i'm like jesus dude go to the
hospital get some stitches yeah he's
hardcore i think he's having fun doing
that
yeah i'd have never met him but like the
vibe i get when he posts the pictures
and the tweets about him
getting beat up or punched or whatever i
kind of i get the sense that it doesn't
bother you
there's a uh there's there's this thing
i heard uh about
firefighters who wish for fires wow it's
it's true though because
uh so so my dad was a firefighter and he
explained to me that some people get
this thing where
they get depressed when they're not
doing something like their job is to
help people and save lives
and then they go weeks with like no fire
or no real calls
and they feel useless so they start
wishing for fires like
inside in their own minds like i want
that fire i want to run in and that's a
scary thought because they're like
they want the destruction but because
they're it reminds me of like
the dogs on 911 you know you know about
the dogs on 911 no
they would have to bury themselves and
then have the dogs find them
because the dogs were getting
demoralized by not finding the bodies
wow
so they would have to pretend to do it
to give the dog like because it's a
feeling everybody gets and they feel
like they're not doing anything about
helping not being useful
yeah i can relate to this story i one of
the reasons why i stopped going out on
the street as much is because
i found myself hoping
that something terrible would happen and
that's a bad feeling like i didn't i
didn't like it i don't want to hope that
ever right so i would go out and if
nothing bad happened i would say
publicly like oh this is great thank god
nothing bad happened but in my mind i'm
like hey i'm coming out here to work
right like where is it you know sure and
i didn't like that feeling at all
journalism in general is a tough job
because
if bad stuff doesn't happen what's the
news like good news doesn't really fly
dude dude have you guys seen bruce
almighty no
no you've not seen it well the movie the
movie the movie almighty
where jim carrey is a local news
reporter and they're like
go do the cookie story the world's
biggest cookie and he's like come on man
and he really wants to be an anchor and
so the movie is basically
he's complaining about life he blames
god for everything
so god morgan freeman grants him the
powers of god and says
you be god and then what does he do he
starts making like meteors crash into
the earth
he's like they find jimmy hoffa's grave
or whatever he's making all this crazy
sensational news that he's right there
for
he falsely frames his rival news team
for having a bunch of pot in their car
and they get arrested by the feds like
totally the russians
super brutal but like i think that
that's
it's i know it's a fictional movie but
it's a play on an idea we
know they call him mrexclusive because
he was finding all of those
big breaking news stories of shocking
explosions and drug busts
so yeah if it bleeds it leads ba bad
news doesn't sell
the movie night crawler was like dude
that movie is so good
have you seen nightcrawler i haven't i i
have some i have some pop culture
deficiencies i'll admit that
but nightcrawler is a movie for anybody
who agrees with trump on fake news
if if you've seen trump say the fake
news and you're like that's right go
watch nightcrawler
and i i can't believe there's not more
like lefties or like that movie is is is
is awful
that making journalists look like
sociopaths because the dude in the movie
is great
it's so good dude long story short i
don't want to ruin the movie it's about
a sociopath
who figures out he can make money
selling if it bleeds it leads
so take that basically all dude
it's it's such a good movie man because
it's not like it's a murderer or
anything
kind of you got to see the movie i don't
want to spoil it for people but it's
it's
so good he's legit trying to like
i don't want to ruin the movie but
journalists who
want to make the story happen
essentially you know
they know well i mean you have every
incentive in the world to make that
happen
fame power money reputation career
stability i mean if you that's how you
make your money then of course you're
going to want to see that
fortunately the cops and the firemen
don't get paid for crime
and fires necessarily cops do have a
quota quotas are very weird like you got
to find the guys that break the law
you're going to get in trouble with your
department so they're out there
making it happen they claim there's no
quotas right they say over and over
again there's no quotes
some departments have them and some
don't they do no no but the stats have
to be good
right right right and in chicago
everybody always knew don't
be careful driving at the end of the
month that's what everyone would always
say
so it's kind of like is it one of those
myths or whatever thanks for checking
out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you